on the dark night we had a great  experience with IMAX and with releasing  the film shooting the film and I'm  accent releasing it on those massive  screens I think it's an incredibly  immersive way for an audience to connect  with a movie inception as a film that  asks the audience to come on a journey  into the human mind into layers of  dreaming and the infinite possibilities  of that it's an incredibly immersive  experience and on imax i think the  audience is going to get the best  version of that almost huge screens with  the amazing sound we've done all kinds  of things to reformat the film for the  imax experience we shot significant  portions of the film on 65 mil large  format film and we're able to scan put  that out 6k resolution on the film print  of the imax experience you get enhanced  clarity you get a closer relationship  with the action it really throws you  into the action I think it's going to be  a really amazing way to see inception